All right, so once we've let the business owner know who we are and we've done this
miniature transition into what we're doing, giving them a damn good reason, we're going
to now explain why we're calling.
We got to let these guys know, or these ladies, guys, whatever, we got to let them know why
we're calling and why it's important they listen to us because we're interrupting their
day.
They do not want to be interrupted.
You got to give them a damn good reason, and it better be different than everybody else.
Now I do want to mention this.
I know that in this entire process, as I've talked about, and I've mentioned this before,
that we talk about the transition at the end of the hook, but there's also miniature transitions
in between each step, and so here's what's cool about this, is after in the first step
when you ask the three questions, you pattern, interrupt, tell them who you are, typically
what's going to happen is the business owner at some point is going to cut you off and
go, wait, wait, who are you?
Basically what they're saying is, who the hell are you, why are you calling me?
You didn't mention who you are, are you a real estate agent, are you a contractor trying
to send me work, is this your house?
They're going to ask something of that version, or some version of that, and that's going
to be a perfect opportunity for you to just segue, transition directly into what you're
doing.
Here's the steps you're going to follow.
Once they ask that, let's pretend that they do that.
What we're going to do now, and when we're explaining this, we're going to ask a couple
things.
We're going to say a couple things.
First of all, we're going to tell them our name, and we're going to tell them that we
have a website in this city.
Then we're going to tell them that we do not have a company, but that we have jobs.
We don't have a tree company, per se.
We don't do tree work, we don't do concrete work, but we have jobs coming in every single
week.
Then we're going to tell them that we call them specifically because we saw that they
were paying for leads, or paying for ads, or paying for whatever, or did this.
We know that that means they're hungry to grow, and then we're going to transition into
the deal.
What does that look like?
We get done, they're like, hey, so who are you?
Oh, sorry.
By the way, Jack, my name is Nick.
The reason I'm calling you is because I have a website here in Austin, here in, we want
them to know that we're local, I have a website here in Austin that gets three to five concrete
jobs every single week, and I don't do concrete.
I have a website here in Austin, here in St. George, here in whatever, and I don't do concrete,
but it's getting X amount of jobs.
If you don't have a site already, you're just doing a pre-sell, don't say more than three
to five, because three to five is a really safe number that you're going to expect off
of ads.
If you have a site that's been producing for years, and this sucker's pulling in 20 a week,
go ahead and say it, but let's not oversell this from day one.
Let's not oversell at all, but especially not from the first conversation.
Hey, I got a website here in Austin, it's getting three to five concrete jobs every
single week, and I don't do concrete.
We said that.
The reason I'm specifically calling you, Jack, is I noticed you're paying for Google Ads,
so I know that you are hungry to grow, or at least I assumed you would like a job.
I assumed you'd be happy to take on this job that I have, I have this lady named Janet,
whatever.
That's it.
We're just going to, and this step right here, we have to let them know why we are calling,
what we're doing.
Got to give them that reason.
Those are the main things that I like to hit is, they're going to cut you off in the middle
of step one, transitioning to step two, they're going to ask who the hell you are, and you're
literally just going to tell them, hey, sorry, Jack, my name's Nick, I have a website here
in Bentonville, Arkansas.
Don't say Arkansas, because that makes it sound like you're out of state.
I have a website here in Bentonville, it's getting three to five concrete jobs every
single week.
I specifically found you on purpose, because I saw you're paying for Google Ads, so I
already know you're hungry to grow, and I'm looking for someone to take on these jobs,
or I'm looking to work with somebody on an ongoing basis.
I don't actually have a concrete company.
You notice how when I explained that the first time, and now I explained it the second time,
I said that differently, but it was the exact same thing.
It's not about saying the exact phrase, and by the way, I'm going to give you guys, there's
going to be a PDF, there's going to be an exact script that you can follow, but I want
you to notice, you can say things multiple ways, and still convey the same message.
Sometimes I'll first tell them I don't have a company, but I have jobs, sometimes I have
jobs coming in, and I'll forget to mention I have a company.
The main point is, you want to be honest and direct and say, hey, I don't have a company,
I got jobs coming in, I have a job right now that's hot as hell, it's ready to go.
Notice how I didn't even said that.
This is my third time kind of explaining it, and this is the first time I'm saying I have
a specific job right now.
I don't want you guys to stress so much.
I'm going to give you the exact script, I just want to break down the important points
to hit.
We talked about the first part, which is who you are.
The second part is why you're calling them.
You have to have a good reason, and it has to make sense.
What makes sense to me, if I put myself in their shoes, is, hey, this kid has a website,
he's getting jobs, he doesn't actually have a concrete company, and he's calling me because
I'm already spending money on ads so he knows that I'm hungry.
That makes sense to me.
By the way, Jack, I have this lady named Janet, she's at Silver Beach Circle, she needs a
tree removed.
This is where we're going to transition into the deal.
And so, I have this lead, her name's Janet, that's our transition.
We're going to then transition into the third step.
So guys, don't overthink it, I just want you to get through these videos.
In the last video of this module, I'm going to give you an example from A to Z, and it's
going to be as closely as I can following the script.
But I'm telling you guys, I've done this so many times, I've said it so many times, it's
just ingrained in my mind, and sometimes I mix up the order.
Sometimes it just flows differently.
I know the steps, I know the things, you have to tell them who you are, you have to tell
them what you're doing, what the deal is, you have to transition.
But sometimes they're out of order, and it's okay because it sounds more natural.
So step two of the perfect prospecting script is a damn good reason why you're calling,
and tell them exactly, not mincing words, why it is that you're interrupting their day.